explicitly rejected and that's what i
believe has happened here
lawrence kansas jeremy independent
thank you for taking my call
in terms of understanding this current
political moment and the apparent level
of criminality that we're dealing with
i'd like to quickly bring up some books
the authors and content of which c-span
should seriously consider featuring
especially in relationship to featuring
a guest like alan dershowitz and his
background and personal commitments
number one house of trump house of putin
the untold story of donald trump and the
russian mafia by craig unger really
gives the background of the trump
organization as a money-long money
laundering organization that fits into
the actual russian deep state i.e
national security apparatus with uh tied
into organized crime number two red
mafia how the russian mob has invaded
america by deceased journalist robert
friedman and then number three the set
of books proof of collusion how trump
betrayed america and now proof of
conspiracy how trump's international
collusion is threatening american
democracy by seth abramson and then
finally i would ask mr dershowitz to
also address the uh topic of uh zev
chalet at narrative the israeli-born
former cbs news executive producer and
whitney webb who have reported that
jeffrey epstein was being run by israeli
military intelligence as uh disclosed by
ari ben menasha and the allegations in
the book robert maxwell israel super spy
that the jalane maxwell father robert
maxwell was a kgb and israeli
intelligence agent who worked with the
red mafia and moghalevic to set up
money laundering instruments around the
world so mr dershowitz your background
in defending uh pollard and and then
epstein suggest that you might be an
agent of a russian israeli axis so i'd
ask you to address that
from from a jewish american patriot of
conscience perspective that's me okay i
mean that's just paranoid uh
drivel the fact that i'm a russian agent
and i'm an israeli agent i'm an
independent person i represented
jonathan pollard because i thought his
sentence was way way uh excessive and
the idea that russian and israel
combined together they're basically
enemies i mean russia supports
syria russia supports iran russia
supports indirectly hezbollah
people who are dedicated to the complete
destruction of israel russia votes
against israel the united nations on
almost every occasion i'm very proud of
my uh career as a criminal defense
lawyer i have defended some of the most
controversial uh people in history um i
think of myself in the tradition of john
adams who represented the boston
massacre soldiers who were accused
i think of myself in the tradition of so
many other defense lawyers throughout
history who have
endured criticism for defending the most
unpopular people of their age and
generation i i'm 81 years old i hope to
continue to defend people you don't like
and people who most americans don't like
because the need for a defense attorney
to stand up to
excesses of the prosecution and paranoid
excesses of the kind you've expressed in
in your views about uh epstein working
for the most
what intelligence agency would trust
jeffrey epstein uh to work
for them uh it these are just uh these
are just allegations that are being uh
thrown out there there's there's no no
truth whatsoever to any of them and
certainly no truth to any claim that i
have ever been an agent for any foreign
country i'm a loyal patriotic american
my grandparents came here to get away
from the oppressions of eastern europe
we love america we're patriotic and i'm
going to continue to do what i think the
american constitution demands of me
defend people who are accused wrongly or
rightly of serious matters
we'll go to west bend wisconsin bill's
watching there republican line you're
next
yes thank you for taking my call also i
have a question on
they say that
was he wanting a